hola hoy en science click la
superposición cuántica
en el universo los objetos se
caracterizan por un conjunto de
magnitudes como la posición la velocidad
o la masa
para cada una de estas cantidades se
puede efectuar una medición por ejemplo
se puede pensar una manzana con una
balanza y medir su masa así podemos
asignar un valor preciso a la masa de
esta manzana sin embargo incluso si no
hemos pesado aún la manzana ya tiene una
masa definida el hecho de pesar la
manzana solamente revelará el valor de
esta masa
el estado de la manzana el conjunto de
todos los valores que pueden medirse
permanece invariable
independientemente de que se haya
realizado la medición o no
sin embargo si nos interesamos en
escalas cada vez más pequeñas varios
fenómenos sorprendentes empiezan a
manifestarse y esta descripción del
mundo deja de ser apropiada si nos
interesamos en la posición de una
partícula fundamental ésta podría estar
en un estado
[Música]
también podría estar en el estado de
donde su posición estará en el punto b
sin embargo la partícula también podría
estar en un estado más complejo formado
a la vez por los estados a ive
en este estado superpuesto a ive podrían
intervenir en proporciones iguales pero
también en un estado superpuesto o
podría intervenir más que p
o por el contrario ha podido intervenir
mucho menos que ve
en este estado de superposición la
partícula no se encuentra ni en a
miembro como tampoco está en los dos
lugares al mismo tiempo la partícula
sencillamente no tiene una posición
definida la propia noción de posición
carece de sentido en la escala cuántica
si intentamos observar esta partícula se
produce entonces un fenómeno contrario a
la intuición al momento de la medición
la medición proyectará de forma
aleatoria su estado determinando al azar
su posición en el punto a y el punto b
se observara entonces que la partícula
se sitúa bien en o bien en vez tiene una
posición definida pero antes de ser
observada habría sido imposible predecir
qué posición habría de tomar es la
medición de su posición la que determina
el estado de la partícula entre los
estados de los que dispone
aunque es imposible predecir en qué
posición se proyectará la partícula es
posible conocer la probabilidad de que
se encuentra en la posición a la
posición b
si uno de los dos estados es
predominante en la superposición inicial
es más probable que sea en ese estado
concreto en el que se proyecte la
posición de la partícula por ejemplo si
la superposición implicará una gran
proporción del estado a una proporción
menor del estado b entonces habría más
posibilidades de encontrar la partícula
en el punto a aunque lo contrario sigue
siendo posible
por último en nuestro caso la
sobreposición involucra únicamente a los
estados y es imposible que la partícula
se proyecte en un estado distinto de la
posición o de la posición b sin embargo
en la naturaleza las partículas se
encuentran en estados superpuestos que
implican todas las posiciones en el
espacio al observar estas partículas es
muy probable que se proyecte en una
posición predominante en lugar de una
posición que intervenga poco
esta descripción permite así establecer
una especie de curva que corresponde a
la probabilidad de observar la partícula
en cada posición el hecho de que las
partículas puedan así ser descritas por
ondas de probabilidad es la base de
muchos fenómenos cuánticos y en
particular la dualidad onda corpúsculo
[Música]